bonjour j'espère que vous allez bien
moi je suis pas au top j'imagine
cacahuètes
[Musique]
j'appelle ça du tout
par politesse numéro là ça va mal
[Musique]
et je voudrais bien un petit peu voilà
barça sion un petit peu
j'appelle parce que je ne gêne pas les
gt chose de grand a confié
[Musique]
parce que bon c'est souvent très seul
coup
voilà j'avais envie d'échanger un petit
peu de sous
elle me dérange pas
sur le sujet
qu'il ya des sujets qui me tiennent à
coeur vous voulez
payer ce que je vis en fait du coup
changé et il
ne pas être assez sûrement quoi donc
j'en ai quelques réactions en ajoutant
du coup vous dit tout puisque vous avez
eu
photo rien voilà des choses comme ça
si votre insu
on n'a pas accepté parce que
vous parlez de suicide assisté
ou vous parliez de suicide assisté pour
nous devons partir d'un roman de pas
accepté
ah bon j'ai dit que je voulais pas être
moi et finalement
sous libre de disco bulli de palu
jusqu'où vous l'ayez pas d'eux des
obligés de rire ici
c'est tout l'inversé les chouchous
la solitude c'est
à la fois ce le fait d'être
seul mais seuls donc sans les autres et
ceci je pense être seul avec soi même
parce qu'on peut se comment dire on perd
quelque chose quand on perd les autres
on perd quelque chose de nous mêmes donc
c'est aussi une solitude très très
personnelle intime c'est pas juste le
fait qu'il ya personnes autour de nous
c'est qu'on se sent seul mais même avec
soi-même plumes au final
c'était votre votre passion commune
c'est ça les voyages
il ya plus en plus de solitude
d'ailleurs je crois qu entre 2017 et
aujourd'hui on est passé de 300 mille à
cinq cent mille personnes en situation
de mort sociale c'est à dire qu'ils ont
aucune mais aucune relation et donc
c'est ça dit quelque chose de notre
société
[Musique]
je me souviens de la sonnerie de la
première écoute
ça a été un peu un moment de stress
en me disant est ce que je réponds
est-ce que je vais être à la hauteur
parce que
avec mon métier d'anciens militaires et
puis je dirais ma façon d'être et de
penser
moi tout est préparé
là forcément s'est pas préparé je ne
sais pas de quoi on va parler est-ce que
je vais et des dentelles direction ou
dans l autre je ne sais pas à l'avant ce
je ne sais pas
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai peut-être ce
petit coup d'adrénaline au moment de la
sonnerie du téléphone
mais j'aime bien
on reproche bon jour pour être mis en
relation avec un aidant tapez 1 avec nos
proches me frecon agréable moment des
changes allô
bonjour
[Musique]
vous êtes aidantes oui ouais alors vous
aider qui
[Applaudissements]
contient
[Musique]
les bipolaires d'accord et e
vous vous avez
mis en place des choses pour les délais
suivi et son côté en pièces
est ce que je sais c'est difficile
à suivre
oh et puis
on est né doit se faire tester pour des
troubles du spectre autistique que je
travaille à temps plein
je tiens toi voudra
reprendre et rend les médicaments à
bouger avant dix jours
à errer aidera va tirer
et le champ nom contient
d'accord moi aussi c'était mon épouse
inquiète restez pas la bipolarité mais
on voudrait c'est ça qui est le plus
fatiguant c'est que on voudrait tout
faire pour que tout redevienne
je dirais bien et ça c'est le vrai que
ben on n'a pas cette possibilité là vous
en avez fait déjà beaucoup vous ce que
vous avez fait c'est déjà énorme donc il
faut un petit peu
pensé à vous et de temps en temps je
dirais
lever un petit peu le pied et parce que
ce qu'il faut bien vous dire c'est que
ça fait partie de la sécurité pour les
proches que vous aider et il faut bien
être persuadé que tout ce que vous
faites
beaucoup de personnes ne le ferai pas
donc il faut être
admiratifs de vous même en réalité
c'est ce que vous faites beaucoup de
personnes ne le ferai pas donc c'est
très beau c'est très beau
[Applaudissements]
mon épouse en fait elle était
insuffisante respiratoire grave c'est à
dire que à la fin et il lui restait 16 %
de capacité respiratoire à dire trois
fois rien et les trois dernières années
elle était traquée ont misé et donc
branché en permanence sur un respirateur
il y avait des gestes infirmier a
réalisé un des aspirations trachéale
donc ça c'est des choses qu'il faut
faire alors au départ c'était à peu près
toutes les deux heures mais c'est vrai
que vers la fin c'était plutôt toutes
les heures ou toutes les demi heures et
ça jour ou nuit c'est pareil donc ce qui
veut dire que pour moi je ne pouvais pas
dormir plus de deux heures de suite
et ça sur trois ans c'est c'est pas
tenable en réalité c'est pas tenable
donc j'ai craqué physiquement je pouvais
plus rien faire en fait et je pense que
ça a été très difficile pour elle
est ensuite allée elle est décédée et à
partir de ce moment là en fait
je moi j'ai voulu m'investir
justement dans la cause des aidants en
me disant que ce que j'avais vécu
si je pouvais aider des gens à le vivre
en tout cas mieux c'est pas ne pas le
vivre parce que voilà il le vivront mais
en tout cas le vivre mieux
c'est quelque chose d'important pour moi
et je me dis que en parler la sphère
la rendre utile je trouve que au moins
elle a pas souffert pour rien et pour
moi c'est une façon de
de la faire vivre en fait de
qu'elle soit toujours là
et vraiment peut-être besoin que je dis
g4 à faire quoi
pour vous le retrouvez
le fait qu'il faut pas
nous avait dit
[Musique]
ça fait
je ne sais pas sur jour
j'arriverai
sacrifiant je ne sais pas si j'arriverai
à exister
et ça c est une autre c'est une très
très belle
mécanique à manger bas desquels tout
conte épique et puis voilà je m'engage à
faire
ce qu'il doit être traité ranspach mais
que cela et puis ben voila quoi je le
jure
oui peut-être d'autres notre façon
d'avancer aussi
vous essayer en tout cas oui mais je
comprends plus comment on vit en lui je
comprendrais jamais chaque complètement
en fermant ils n'y arrivent pas ils le
cherchent
et trouvent et quand même 6 4
je vais demander est ce que c'est
possible
que au moment du lancement et elle a
répondu oui
c'est possible mais on pouvait même un
nom aussi en guérir
on peut aussi en guérir
la première fois que j'appelle un numéro
comme ça
pour parler
je sais bien que j'ai mûri un mot tu es
parti pour tout à fait vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est pour ça que
nous sommes là donc
[Musique]
parfois le psychiatre est pas disponible
au moment où il faudrait parfois laminé
pas disponibles nous nous
nous sommes là 24 heures sur 24 donc
bon vous avez fait là le premier rappel
mais
voilà n'hésitez pas
[Musique]
à trèbes miracle mais on est la rue on
est là
beaucoup
appris je me dis je dis au revoir il
pique nous rappeler quand vous me
me dis enfin entre
une des choses qu'on nous apprend
beaucoup à utiliser ça va être le
silence le silence qui est très
important pour permettre à l'appelant
de parler à son propre rythme
sans jugement sans conseil il appelle
pas pour qu'on lui dise ce qu'il a à
faire
l'appelant ils appellent pour parler
parce que on sait qu'aujourd'hui
parler est probablement là moyen le plus
efficace pour lutter contre le passage à
l'acte
[Musique]
sida info service
je vais à l'eau pour toi bonsoir oui
bonsoir à tous et moi il ya deux
semaines
avec tuer pour un
employé le mot pour que j'ai pas avec
abbaoui goûté on a l'habitude ça c'est
notre métier vous savez en temps parler
de sexualité toute la journée un
concert mille étudiants non c'est sûr il
ya beaucoup d'études savez le vih était
découvert en 1983 ça fait presque 40 ans
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'études là vous me l'avez dit ma vie
dit est ce que je peux dire les mots etc
vous avez dit dès le départ je me suis
fait sucer par une prostituée
en se faisant sucer il n'y a pas de vih
c'est en suçant
occupée pour la personne qu'ils
suspectent rabel vih
on rapporte aussi
lui 500 le sexe pas de la glace un sexe
d'accord mais pas tout de suite ok parce
que jean tu le vois pas passer une bonne
soirée l'autre au revoir
peut pas passer une journée sans
fellation ça c'est pas possible
je suis écoutant à sida info service
depuis
30 ans déjà donc le temps passe très
vite j'ai pas vu le temps passer
je me suis retrouvé assis l'info service
par hasard mais
mais j'avais perdu des amis du sida donc
j'avais déjà été percuté par le
sida à l'époque on appelait ça même au
début le cancer gay et chercher un
travail c'est une amie qui avait amené
cette cette annonce
c'était comme si
oui il n'ya pas de hasard n'y a que des
rendez vous c'est comme si cette copine
me mettez ça devant le nez en disant ça
tu recherches du boulot elle avait des
dons qu'elle avait vu d'autres annonces
mais elle me disait c'est pour toi et et
l avez compris en fait
alors en fait qu'un appel parce que là
je suis - 21h et le cyan avec un aplomb
qui est totalement
en détresse en fait il est en train d
accompagner son mari qui est en train de
mourir ils pensent qu'il va mourir cette
nuit donc je ne veux absolument pas le
laisser comme ça tout seul mais il faut
impérativement que je parte je voulais
pas je pouvais être le transférer en
fait alors tu me dis qu'il accompagne
son mari c'est ça ouais
et son mari est mourant way du sida lé
dakor dit beaucoup jean moulin prise
sans procare enfin au revoir
bonsoir
et suicide écoute bonjour oui
bon ça
va très
bientôt si j'allais bien je crois que je
vous appellerai pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai perdu mon fils unique
les u13 tu ne sors pas de bannière
la vôtre votre fils est décédé il ya
longtemps maintenant
alan hahn hon
et vous avez du mal à faire le deuil
[Musique]
oui
j'ai commencé à penser au bénévolat
lorsque je me suis senti inutile
comme femme au foyer puisque jallet de
l'été pendant très très longtemps ça
correspondait à une période de ma vie où
j'avais plus d'enfants et même occupé
chez moi il était grand mon mari bien
sûr travailler et
je me suis dit au lieu de de perdre ton
temps là chez toi dans tes casseroles
etc tu vas enfin servir à quelque chose
tu vas pouvoir être utile voilà
sos homophobie bonsoir
bonsoir
j'ai pour elle en fait un complément
nuit en gros il est urgent
avec mon ancien collègue
et elle a utilisé le prétexte là pour me
out et à ma famille à et a du coup c'est
pour l'avoir les recours juridiques
si si si si on n'a pas le droit de faire
du outing c'est puni par la loi
alors nous avons un parmi nos diverses
activités une commission juridique ils
peuvent lui envoyer un courrier à elle à
celle qui a fait le outing alors là ça
peut être positif parce qu'elle n'a pas
le droit de faire ça
et qui bien sûr
incite à nous absolument pas recommencer
voilà ce que c'est inadmissible
ok il ya longtemps que ça s'est passé
cette vous parler c'est encore ce qu il
a évolué à bah oui ouais ouais et alors
ça s'est passé comment alors votre
famille vis-à-vis de luz a créé un bon
solo
[Musique]
ah oui à ce point là bas du coup est
parti j'ai ma famille pour les études et
le
factuel et ailleurs et du coup elles est
la contraction tu vas les quatre trios
il n'y a pas moyen de dialoguer avec
d'autres familles par téléphone ou y'a
pas moyen
comme suit je pense que telle a fait le
choix que j'ai peur sachez que j'ai
entre nous donne tort ou qui a pouvait
changer plus tard
changé c'est à dire le regard qu'à votre
famille visage ne faut pas jouer
si vous pouvez arriver à dialoguer un
petit peu expliquer ce que c'est pas un
choix enfin bon
un tas de choses qu'ils peuvent
comprendre ça pourrait peut-être
arranger les choses il va falloir du
temps ça va pas se faire du jour au
lendemain mais
ce que je fous pas bon une rupture
complète
ça va âtre ici tout le monde des deux
côtés
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ce qu'il
vous fallait n'y a rien de
d'accord et d'un bon courage bonne
soirée
au revoir
la formation ça demande un minimum d'un
an j'ai dû être dans les premières quand
même longtemps qu'hétérosexuels
à sos homophobie
dans la vie la mixité dans tous les
domaines je pense que c'est important
donc je veux pas me retrouver dans la
club de tricot ou de
là au moins ce qui est sûr c'est que les
autres personnes n'ont pas le même
profil que moi
j'avais rencontré des gens du centre
lgbt
cette fameuse joël entre autres elle
s'occupait de lait coûte à l'époque elle
m'a dit viens à faire des coups tu as
homophobie jeudi mais joël tu sais très
bien que je suis hétéro lundi et alors
ça t'empêche d'écouter et de répondre
lui dit non mais enfin ils n'ont pas les
bons pas me prendre mais annie dit tu
vas tu faire comme tout le monde tu vas
à une réunion recrutement tu dis voilà
je suis hétéro mais je serais intéressé
par les coups depuis tu verras bien et
ça a démarré comme ça j'ai été étonné en
arrivant chez sos que personne n'ait
rien demandé à bâle entre de montguyon
annonce à la une est mineur mais
je ressentais plus besoin de diab avait
bonjour cher nike ligue et on s'en
foutait je sais pas avant c'était une
question qui me trottaient dans un tel
vraiment avant de rentrer chez elles
souhaitent et en rentrant je me suis dit
bon oui oui c'est peut-être mieux d'être
concernés mais au final
et moi on va tous demander c'est bien
sûr même en ligne le tu réponds quoi que
je dis je n'ai pas à répondre à cette
question l'important c'est que j'ai
choisi de devenir écoutante et
mais oui où
pensez vous que ça change quelque chose
ou un
et là je sais pourquoi c'est parce
qu'ils ont ils pensent que tu comprendra
mieux cités concernées ce qui est
peut-être vrai ça je
je sais pas
je pense que n'importe qu'elle écoute en
écoutant ti il ya eu des trucs dans sa
vie avant
qu'il a sensibilisé à je pense qu'il
faut un point de dépôt départ comment on
ne vient pas comme ça tout en écoutant
ça nous prend pas comme ça d'un seul
coup
je crois pas
j'ai eu dans ma vie moi des périodes
très très long moment j'ai perdu mon
mari mais malheureusement mon père très
tôt il m'aura cinquantaine d'années ma
mère est morte d'une façon dramatique à
41 ans donc je pense que ça m'avait déjà
aguerris à tous à tous que
voilà je n'étais pas insensible à tout à
des choses quand même assez assez
perturbante
donc je pense pouvoir comprendre ce
qu'une autre personne qui vit des choses
elle même dramatique et tout peut
ressentir puisque je les ressentais
d'une façon différente mais j'ai
ressenti
les personnes qui se propose
pour être écoutant ou écoutante c'est
des personnes qui
qui savent déjà en partie ce dont elles
sont capables
il ya des gens qui liront ans non mais
moi je serai jamais écoutant je peux pas
olemps et c'est l'instinct qui parle
aussi
et quand vous leur dites banon vous
voyez bien que c'est pas fait cas ce que
parce qu'elles répondent
d'accord
bon bah tant mieux
n'hésitez pas à rappeler sans je vous en
avez besoin ou envie et puis j'espère
que ça va marcher pour votre randonnée
je vous souhaite plein de courage merci
bonne soirée au revoir
pluie donc là bas comme tu le sais là je
n'ai pas mais je n'ai pas entendu ce que
disait la personne je me suis concentré
maman sort 3
alors de façon générale ne pas être trop
dans la conversation les symboles espace
à l'autre évidemment il faut que tu
montres à l'autre côté présent que tu
l'accueil que de soit que tu montres que
tu es bienveillant côté chaleureux que
juge pas donc c'est évidemment beaucoup
tu sois présent mais laissé de l'espace
à l'autre passe par le silence
les cayes que j'avais identifié c'est
puis pas de poser des questions qui sont
presque plus pour satisfaire sa
curiosité que pour aider la personne ou
ma compréhension
effectivement ce qui compte c'est pas
forcément ta compréhension du problème
mais c'est laisser l'espace à l'autre
qui juste qu'elle puisse s'exprimer pas
plaquer ton système de penser à comment
il va raconter ce oui mais oui
aujourd'hui par exemple par rapport à
personne que j'avais écouté en double
écoute au début elle avait vraiment
besoin de déverser
[Musique]
ça y est tu déconnes bonjour bah oui oui
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup d'appels
je me souviens quand
lors de ma formation l'admets formateur
m'avait dit n'essaye pas d'avoir deux
projets pour l'appelant ça ne marchera
pas et effectivement les quelques fois
où j'ai pu avoir un projet en lui disant
fais ceci fait cela je me suis pris une
claque monumentale parce que l'appelant
me disais mais vous avez rien compris
madame peut-être c'est immédiat ces
retours de re revers immédiats en fait
il ya une question de garder la bonne
distance de bon positionnement un peu un
peu comme un funambule
ça qu'on doit être à la fois
pas trop distant ça peut être violent de
renvoyer un mur de silence
et en même temps on peut pas être
intrusif et directif parce que c'est
laisser la place à l'autre alors parfois
c'est dur de le faire parce que c'est
pas forcément naturel mais c'est
important et puis ça permet à beaucoup
de choses qui se disent dans les
sciences
[Musique]
bon je comprends en fait vous souhaitez
avoir ce résultat avançant que votre
mari soit au courant en fait c'est ça
et d'éventuellement préparer si c'était
positif
voilà esquermes ce que vous dites et
vous le dit spontanément c'est que vous
êtes en tension
actuellement qui a beaucoup disputé que
quand il
actuellement c'est constamment en fait
constamment depuis mon scanner on est
constamment dans le cube quoi et depuis
que je suis arrivé en france pas double
email d'ailleurs dont je suis tout le
temps en fait
ça a doublé parce que vous n'êtes pas
dans votre pays c'est pour ça que je
suis là parce que je suis pas dans mon
pays en fait j'ai pas d'argent tout ce
que j'avais des ailes d'avion ma voiture
que j'ai
besoin de faiblesse aller nulle part
vous êtes dépendant alors vous êtes
dépendant à la psychose passe mal dans
votre pays vous lui dites chao je vais
voir quelqu'un de ma famille pendant
trois jours je vais prendre l'air et
puis là il sait que vous êtes un petit
peu captive c'est que bon là on qu'on
parle de plusieurs aspects mais là il ya
beaucoup de niveaux différents au départ
vous m'avez demandé
une adresse pour avoir un autotest
gratuit et en fait il ya tout un toute
une histoire derrière tout ça voyez
il est il est un peu violent quand même
votre partenaire
vous me dites qui vous a tapé avec votre
portable sur au niveau du visage en
jeu le
fruit mais enfin c'est quand même un
acte parce que là c'est quand même il ya
des choses qui sont moi je vous dis pas
forcément d'aller à la police mais vous
pouvez vous soustraire à la violence de
l'autre en partant
à sheila cas parce que là vous m'avez
pas beaucoup parler d'amour quand même
en fait ça me fait beaucoup de bien
mesurer souvent
je vous souhaite du courage du courage
et du courage voilà ça mon programme ça
croyez pas
prenez soin de vous ramène
voir par
moi j'estime faire de l'artisanat en
fait c'est ont créé une création en fait
c'est
il faut être
réceptif à ce que dit l'autre et puis on
fait un petit peu de la dentelle on fait
un petit peu de la dentelle donc on crée
on ne fait pas toujours la même dentelle
pour tout le monde moi je vois le
travail des coudes comme une oeuvre il
ya quelque chose de l'ordre du roman
c'est pour ça que moi après 30 ans je ne
suis pas là c'est parce que je découvre
toujours quelque chose
[Musique]
alors quand on nous attendait mais paris
- vous n'êtes pas si vous n'avez pas
forcément entendu je vous demandais tout
à l'heure quand elle danse vous phase i
can't dance vous pratiquiez
bypass musée basque landes valse de
vienne et pas ceux d'hommes au tango
argentin
voyez toutes connues des temps tout seul
au monde ah oui nous vous étiez à moi
une fan avoué nous avions nous mêmes on
hamm est beaucoup beaucoup ça ça a été
dit sur notre ville de patience puisque
soixante dix ans avait été un enduit cm
et tous ans et habite ma vie a été l'un
des
puits bon ben si j'ai perdu mon
compagnon
alors on danse était si j'arrête une
danse et
je ne peux pas danser sans lui puis avec
d'autres que lui et voilà pour mature
seulement manger et j'ai pris de l'âge
depuis bombay et moi sa tendance et mes
jambes et tous ses missions du nouveau
lâché
alors
mapala j'assume enfin c'est une partie
de ma vie que tu as été très heureux
j'ai que
c'est que j'aimais beaucoup ce sont de
bons souvenirs ah oui
seigneur des souvenirs c'est ça qui font
ma machine édition oui vous avez des
petits enfants peut-être nuit étoilée
petits enfants et six arrière petits
enfants c'est extraordinaire c'est vrai
on avale un chilien mais vous savez pas
pourquoi je suis resté neuf la maman qui
il fait face à thoune be et brouille
tout ça peu probable c'est presque
mortel
moment ça 90 euros mais maman bon voilà
c'est en france qu'elle touche jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais je ne
reviens jamais qu'ici c'est voulant de
postes non parce que je ne veux pas
assombrir leur négoce non
non non non je souhaite m'éteindre tout
seul comme ça mais à faire souffler
alors je ne veux pas les ennuyer
olalalala alors de bonnes âmes qui se
veut sa mort si je femme ou quand ils
viennent de voila voila je passe ma vie
seuls nous combien avec de subir mich
desjoyeaux
la
zet une battante pourquoi dans la nuit
vous voir
combattre
voilà
tout est à bout du banc merci madame
à revoir
quand on reçoit des appels qu'on écoute
on peut pas 4 dans le pathos parce que
c'est important pour la personne ayant
même en temps de respect de la voir non
pas simplement comme une personne qui
souffre mais la prenant son mythe dans
sa globalité une personne humaine qui
est aussi à la capacité est calé outils
pour
pour rebondir
on enferme pas simplement dans sa
solitude
une allée faire un tour en battue et
bruits
poussières force on dit tous a vu un nom
du tout
débat chercher
c'est la première fois que vous nous
appelez
le nom
est aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui a fait que vous vouliez nous appeler
tous pas me répéter
non pas du tout je suis concentré pour
vous écouter au contraire
au contraire
[Musique]
c'est à dire c'est à dire
non non non je suis pas du pit hâtif je
vous crois je crois
[Musique]
c'est une question plus sûres mal
d'interrogations sur le fait que vous
dites
bien sûr
mais vous me posez des questions
je cherchais à comprendre ce que vous
disiez
sauf qu'on pose beaucoup de questions
jeudi j'ai l'impression que les gens
sont toujours dans
l'interrogation des chaussures montantes
annick avant
mais en général 1
et quand on est allé avec une personne
écoute on a envie d'être plus à l'aise
que ça monsieur donc c'est pas toujours
le cas
posez-moi des questions parce que je
passe le présent budget coucou avec
un énorme pas refermé
sur lui tout
c'est pas bisounours est le cousin s'est
pas non plus c'est parfois très trash il
ya des gens qui sont très trash il ya
l'agressivité
il ya des gens qui se défoule et c'est
vrai que des fois on entend des choses
qui sont très très difficile parce que
on est un peu
un réceptacle
josé ducamin des plus que fut pendu à
trois semaines d'un mois tu m'as dit
saouad ya la peur moi depuis en prison
j'ai vu de perfection sud
il faut avoir le courage de se pendre
moi je pourrais pas me prendre un pour
le courage
et que je vais dire ça ou deux et bien
dormi je t'informe que
j'entends un peu fatigué
c'est vrai parfois ça m'arrive de
terminer les coupes mais j'ai mal
partout parce que j'ai eu quelqu'un qui
avait une telle énergie de désespoir qui
a fallu
c'est la noyer qui a fallu repêché et
réanimé que je suis j'ai l'impression
qu'on m'a tabassée quoi
[Musique]
j'ai envie de prendre des cachets mais
bon
une autant je sais par un kobe la peau
donc si je rate les problèmes ou
ailleurs je ne comprends pas j'ai pas
les réponses à son à son goût elles sont
à vous c'est vous qui sait c'est votre
vie c'est les réponses parfois les fils
- sont compliqués à chercher on aimerait
tous avoir une petite baguette magique
pour moi mais il répond ça s'entend vous
bon ce que vous dites
[Musique]
oui
je vous souhaite un bon we can et
c'est hyper questionnant sur le sens u16
parfois c'est pas agréable pour moi de
d'être dans cette position où la
personne va mal et la charge des
solutions mois
ne peut pas vraiment lui en donner
je peux pas lui en donner
[Musique]
on y va le principe de partage c'est que
chacun prend un peu la parole comme il
le souhaite jacques et notre
psychanalyste qui est là pour écouter de
ce qu'on a envie de lui raconter de nos
écoutes et il est là pour nous écouter
je suis content des coûtants depuis 25
ans 26 ans quelque chose comme ça qu'ils
envient de d'ouvrir le débat on ayant
quelque chose à raconter
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé hier sur
une des écoutes que j'ai eus que j'ai
prise parce que moi je suis vraiment
débutants c'est la deuxième fois que je
prends des appels et là il ya une jeune
fille qui m'a appelé qui avait fait deux
tentatives de suicide amener des faire
enfin c'était genre elle était chez ses
parents et c'était genre il ya quinze
jours et tout est plus c'est une jeune
fille moi je suis une maman fin il y
avait une espèce d'attention
supplémentaires et elle c'était mon
dernier coup de fil et donc je suis
rentré chez moi et c'est un petit peu
j'étais contente j'étais contente voilà
mais il y avait un truc je me suis dit
bon à la tribune d'où j'ai fait bon
voilà est-ce qu'il ya des voix là il
faut quand même avouer que notre
dispositif est assez singulier
à savoir on écoute d'abord on ne veut
pas dire qu'on a répondu on est d'abord
là pour répliquer sens et pas très
ordinaire dans la vie courante dans la
vie courante on a affaire un conseiller
on a un cerf en faire des gens qui
savent déjà qu'ils vont nous donner une
information des gens qui vont nous
apprendre quelque chose d'assez pas le
cas est censé unis n'étaient pas pas
dire autant moi j'ai un monsieur qui
m'appellent et kim raconte une histoire
un peu compliquée de sa vie
d'alcooliques etc
il était au 36e dessous ils étaient
prêts effectivement à mettre fin à ses
jours et on a parlé pendant très
longtemps sa durée facilement une heure
et à la fin il m'a dit ce qu'on attend
tous quand on voit qu'on attend pas tous
mais on est heureux d'entendre quand
c'était bon je crois que ça m'a fait du
bien
peut-être réfléchir et là on se dit bon
bah on sait pourquoi on est là quand
j'en suis
[Musique]
oh
au quotidien qu'est-ce qui est le plus
dur en fait c'est
c'est l'accumulation des choses à me
laisser penser que je fais pas bien que
je
sais c'est ma mère des fois je me dis va
jouer partout ailleurs je finalise la
gagne si
vous savez bon moi j'ai été dans aussi
alors c'était pas ma mère c'était mon
épouse et
c'est pareil g us et ses pensées là de
me dire j'en peux plus je prends ma
valise et je m'en vais des fois je
prenais
dix minutes un quart d'heure et j'allais
dans la forêt est en fait j'embrassais
un arbre
c'est ça m'a fait énormément de bien en
fait 1,2 dans là c'est un arbre voilà ça
oui
j'avais des rubans verts
il ya certes un appel qui peuvent être
on va pas dire déstabilisant mais qui
touchent plus que d'autres notamment
quand ça ressemble trop à ce que j'ai
vécu
je vais dire un truc je sais pas si tu
le gardes assure le truc mais en fait là
je suis tourné
mon épouse était
là derrière dans un lit médicalisé et en
fait je la vois je donc
voilà c'est plus difficile
[Musique]
dans la vie en général on n'écoute pas
vraiment mon équipe comme ça on a
l'impression d'écouter du style on
croise quelqu'un dans la rue ça va on va
dire ça va oui et toi on n'écoute pas et
si on nous dit non ça va pas on veut
même pas entendre le nom ça va pas or si
on a appris à écouter c'est quelqu'un
nous dit non ça va pas leur ovale
l'entendant on va lui poser la question
qu'est ce qui ne va pas qu'on aurait
peut-être pas demandé avant parce qu'on
fait pas attention dans la vie
[Musique]
dans l'interaction avec les autres on a
tendance à occuper le terrain ramener
les choses à soi combien de fois quand
on raconte quelque chose d'autre dit ah
bah oui d'ailleurs c'est moi j'ai fait
la même chose que c'est un donc c'est
pas écouter écouter c'est pas de
s'insérer dans le discours de l'autre et
mais c'est difficile parce qu'on est
toujours on nous a appris très jeune
qu'il fallait par une opinion sur tout
donc quand quelqu'un vous dit quelque
chose on est toujours amené à dire tu as
eu raison tu as eu tort de faire c'est
de plus en plus l'hôte en général ils
arrivent en disant mais qu'est ce que tu
fais à ma place et c est justement ça
sert à rien parce qu'on n'est jamais à
la place de l'autre
c'est un bénévolat ou il faut rester
très humble
ce qu'on fait c'est
accueillir l'autre avec fracas et et
l'écouté de l'échangé
c'est ça la fois tout petits à la fois
sénat
j'avais besoin de parler je voulais vous
dire que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
vous parce que c'est quelque chose de
merveilleux de rockland ça on a besoin
de vous pour que ça je voulais vous dire
merci et je ne vous connais pas et
soudaine beau
je vous remercie infiniment d'avoir le
plus de temps de méditer
au moins un jour je vais mieux pour
cette soirée et ça me redonne du courage
merci
[Musique]
merci beaucoup je trouve pas de mots
pour remercier mais merci
selon vraiment pour votre confiance
votre influence et ses deux pouces à
dormans s'éclaircit m'avoir écouté
[Musique]
je vous écoute